the way that school exposes you to the
different topics which of course you
should get exposed to them does not
match the way that we learn and so for
example this idea of isolating Topics by
subject and then you know every 45
minutes we ring a bell and you need to
close whatever you were learning in math
and then open up the science and then
close science and then open every 45
minutes that really affects the way that
you're consuming this content the way
our brains work is that learning is
interconnected so you need to be able to
synthesize ideas from different fields
and understand how math fits with
science and literacy and so a way better
way to do it is through projects you
give kids a problem a real challenging
problem and then they're going to need
different tools and different things in
order to solve that problem and that's
the moment where you start introducing
them so kids actually understand why
they're learning this different subjects
all right guys bang bang I've got Anna
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start is you've got this new book
coming out it's all about the learning
game but school is a horrible way for
people to actually learn it's more
something that people just do to try to
get past the game of school what's the
problem in school you're a teacher
you've seen inside the belly of the
Beast like what are the problems and how
do we fix them
yeah so um in my book The Learning game
I talk about the difference between the
game of school and the game of learning
so the game of school is what most kids
learn to master right which is this idea
of raising your hand before you know so
you get that participation grade you
pretend like you're paying attention you
find the shortcut so that you can get
the boring stuff out of the way you do
the assignments you don't question your
teacher so it's all these things that
kids pick up quickly in order to appear
as if they're learning and so that
doesn't really transfer to real learning
which is why a bunch of kids graduate
from high school with a bunch of
academic junk that they don't know how
to apply in the real world and with no
idea of what they're good at what they
want to do how they want to spend the
rest of their lives and so the learning
game
and this is what I talk about in the
book is how do you opt out of that and
actually do the things that will prepare
kids for the real world and so in the
book I present sort of
what the future of Education would look
like or what real learning would look
like if we built a system that was for
the how the world is today and so I go
over the way that kids are being taught
in school right now and then contrast it
to how kids really learn how do they
really learn though like what is the
actual way that they learn so they
learned when they know how to apply what
they're learning to the real world so if
you think about all the things that
they're learning in the curriculum they
often ask why like what is this going to
serve me for and often teachers don't
have an answer the reality is that
two-thirds of the kids going through
grade school right now will end up doing
jobs that haven't been invented yet and
so all this time that they're spending
in school learning and that we're
teaching them is really not that
important because that's constantly and
quickly changing it's way more important
to teach them how to teach themselves
how to pick up the things and the skills
that they need when they need it so
that's one the other thing is
civilization advances only to the extent
that people can think critically and
solve problems together and so the lack
of an education system that cultivates
the skills is therefore our primary
bottleneck in school kids are learning
how to pair it back answers how to mimic
their teachers how to do what everyone
else is doing how to learn to pass a
test and then after the test they forget
I mean think about the things that you
learned in school how much of it
actually stuck over the years or how
much are you actually using nowadays you
know it's it's very rare and one of the
big things like research shows that
knowledge decays really quickly so
unless you are using productively what
you learn you know in the next 14 days
you forget about it and so what I would
see a lot as a teacher and was very
frustrating was that we would spend all
these hours going through these units
and curriculum and tests and all this
and then after the test that kids
usually got good grades then they had no
idea how to apply that to an open-ended
problem and so this was very concerning
I ended up leaving the system trying to
find Alternative Learning experiences
and I came across these guys that were
working at synthesis which we've talked
about in the past and what we're doing
there is actually remarkable work and
what I think will be the future of
education and we can talk about that
innovatively so my experience in uh
middle school and in high school really
high school probably was there was two
different types of Education happening
there was the classroom education and
then there was the hallway education and
I got way more out of the hallway
education than I did in the classroom
and I remember things that they would
teach us like
um dissecting the Frog right you got to
cut up the frog or whatever like you
know kids were first of all doing crazy
stuff and so it like took away from the
lesson but secondly I remember thinking
to myself like what am I really going to
need this right the other thing I always
laugh about is the Pythagorean theorem
right it's like who has used the
Pythagorean theorem at any point in
their life unless you're an engineer
right and so how much of it is like
being exposed to that stuff helps you
understand like ah cool I get the frogs
but like biology is not my thing oh I
get you know this uh you know very kind
of uh um complex math uh equation but
you know what I don't want to be a
mathematician I don't want to go into
that type of field uh in engineering and
so exposure leads you to kind of hone in
on what you actually want to do like how
do you balance I couldn't tell you what
the Pythagorean theorem is today but I
could tell you I knew that after going
and studying some of that stuff I was
like this isn't for me and so like I did
get value but maybe not in the way that
the school intended yeah well here's the
thing
um it the way that school exposes you to
the different topics which of course you
should get exposed to them does not
match the way that we learn and so for
example this idea of isolating Topics by
subject and then you know every 45
minutes we ring a bell and you need to
close whatever you were learning in math
and then open up the science and then
close science and then open every 45
minutes that really affects the way that
you're consuming this content the way
our brains work is that learning is
interconnected so you need to be able to
synthesize ideas from different fields
and understand how math fits with
science and literacy and so a way better
way to do it is through projects or when
you have common like a common theme and
then you start to say okay what do I
need in order to solve you give kids a
problem a real challenging problem and
then they're going to need different
tools and different things in order to
solve that problem and that's the moment
where you start introducing them so kids
actually understand why they're learning
this different subjects and I think that
that would actually change the way you
think about you know becoming a
scientist or becoming you know or
wanting to pursue a career in that field
and so that's one thing and then the
fact that we you know we learning is
very grounded on curiosity so you need
to be very excited about something in
order to learn about it you can't force
kids to learn which is usually what
happens in school like you were saying
now we're going to learn about this but
maybe Anthony wasn't ready to learn
about that at that particular moment
because you were not interested in it
once you develop an interest in
something that's the moment where you
you know that's sort of like your gate
and that's when you take advantage of
that and you teach kids whatever it is
that you want to teach them and so if we
actually and this is something
complicated to do in school when you
have 30 kids and you have a curriculum
to do but if you actually
start by where kids are interest
interested in things are very very
different like the results are and it's
something as simple as that like the
results are very different they actually
absorb the content they want to keep
going because humans and you know
especially kids are hardwired to learn
like we we want to learn we want to
understand things we want to deconstruct
things the problem is that kids enter
Then into a system where suddenly you
know they have no choice over the
subjects that they're learning the way
they're learning the way they have to
Showcase what they're learning
um and then they start to associate
learning with something negative and
then they don't want to do it anymore
and this is really concerning right like
we need to cultivate lifelong Learners
that should be the the whole point of
education and that's really not what's
happening which is one of the reasons
why I left so it seems to me uh my
experience with school is like very
similar to a lot of people who end up
going into certain types of fields right
if you want to be a doctor I've got a
brother who's a doctor like you got to
go through the system you got to get the
licenses you got to go get the education
pass the test I'm like there's a whole
system uh that I think a lot of people
would say we actually want our doctors
to have have a traditional education and
like kind of get all these uh kind of
pass all these filters so that we know
they're high quality for me I hated
regular school like I would spend more
time trying not to do the homework than
if I had just done the homework but if
you sat me down in a class that I was
interested in I get A's and teachers are
always like I don't understand like you
get like a c or a D in this class but
you get an A in this classic how is that
possible it's like I don't care about
that class right but this one I actually
do so how does a school kind of morph
itself or evolve itself in your opinion
to actually almost like fit the content
in the topics to kids like should we
have people go in and say you have to do
four years of science you have to do
four years of math you got to do four
years of this or is it more so like
let's figure out what you're interested
in and then just help you go become more
like that or learn more of that
information and maybe you'll pick up
some science along the way or some math
along the way but it's less of a rigid
uh you know kind of requirement and it's
more so uh outcome based almost than it
is like the input based system that we
have today yeah so a few things here
first I think think that having been in
the system for a long time and trying to
do things differently it's very clear
that the system's broken and it cannot
be fixed and it cannot be reformed it's
always going to be there I really
believe it's going to be hard to get rid
of it because parents need a place to
send their kids to school you know when
they have to work it's a babysitting
center essentially and so that's one of
the main reasons why I don't think it's
going to go away but that being said you
know we need to create an alternative
system like I'm really convinced at the
beginning you know I've spoken to a lot
of people that are trying to reform and
add things and but the outcomes are
pretty much the same the system was
created a long time ago for very
different purposes and we can talk about
that later but um what I've noticed is
that kids like in school we spend
teachers most of our time trying to
remediate kids weaknesses and so we
determine okay Anthony's not good at
this and not good at this and so we
torment you and we put you in support
groups and we try to really instead of
doubling down on the things that you on
your strengths and the things that you
already have a natural talent for and a
desire to do usually people people like
what they're good at and so imagine if
schools actually focused on making you
better at the think that you're already
good at and then obviously get you know
they give you exposed shirt to like a
general content in a more effective way
and we can talk about that later too how
to do that
um but the outcomes would be vastly
different you know kids would be
graduating from
school knowing what they're good at
knowing you know having years of
practice getting even better at that and
so that they can come to the world be
productive and actually be passionate
about doing something that's relevant
and so that's one of the big things like
I was very frustrated how it was always
about remediating kids weaknesses it's
like no like everyone's going to be good
at one thing and not so good at another
thing so instead of trying to make
everyone great at everything let's just
figure out what they're already good at
and make them better at that so that's
one thing and then the other thing is
the way that you expose kids to
different so we've known for the longest
time that the best way to learn you know
hardcore academics is through one-on-one
tutoring
um and you know we've known this for for
many many years you know that's why
Alexander the Great had Aristotle as his
tutor now of course it's not viable for
every kid in the world to have a private
tutor why not um well a one-on-one human
tutor because of resources because you
know like you it's very expensive to get
that so a lot of people wouldn't be able
to however the Holy Grail of education
is how how do we use is to figure out
how we use technology to create a
superhuman tutor that can then teach you
all these things that you learn in
school in hours and you know so many
years and that you don't really learn
effectively and you forget and so at
synthesis you know we've actually this
is part of what we're doing this year we
launched a tutor it's called a synthesis
tutor that is based on groundbreaking
research funded by DARPA you know the r
d Department of the Department of
Defense in America and that they're in
charge of coming up with all the
emerging Technologies to use by the
military so they came up with like the
early GPS the internet early
self-driving cars and so we actually
built upon their discoveries with modern
AI tools and we came up with um a really
interesting solution to this problem of
how do we teach kids hardcore academics
and so the synthesis tutor the way it
works is we've
um built upon the best teachers out
there the best tutors out there so we
record this teachers for hours and hours
and hours and we capture their
mannerisms we captured their examples we
captured their stories because we know
that you know very different from the
apps or GPT or all these things that are
very
um like generic the the synthesis tutor
is actually capturing all the human
elements that make tutors amazing and
we're putting this and making it
available to everyone so what DARPA
discovered a few years ago and they
spent hundreds of millions of dollars
trying to create this technology was
that you know students that used the
digital tutor for 16 weeks to learn it
outperformed Navy technicians that had
been in the field for 10 years so this
is remarkable results right and we're
building upon that to teach kids we
started with math this year but we plan
to use it to teach all stem subjects so
when you look at other tutors out there
like the reason why tutors are so good
is because they take you from the middle
of the pack to the top one percent so
that's like you know the difference
between going to community college and
going to an Ivy League pretty remarkable
our tutor is way better than that it
will take you from the 50th percentile
to the 99.99999 percentile and so these
are the results that they got back then
with the students and we're seeing sort
of the same results right now and we're
very optimistic that if we use this
technology to teach all subjects we are
going to have you know this is the kind
of thing that pushed civilization
forward this is the kind of thing that's
really changing the way that we teach
and learn and so what would happen is
that your kids would be learning in an
hour a day from the best you know
technology out there this core academics
and then they would have the rest of the
day to actually be kids a lot of what's
happened with the traditional school
system is that we've robbed kids from
their childhood it's the most important
and formative years of their lives that
they're spending you know five days a
week for seven hours a day for 12 years
stuck in this places where they can
barely move they can't talk they can't
do the things that we know that kids
need to do in order to develop as
healthy and happy individuals it's a
legal prison it's a legal prison there
you go yes I can say that you probably
can't say that right yes yes there you
go um I do agree with you though and so
um imagine if we're able to do that and
and we can talk about you know how like
I've after I saw the way that the tutor
the digital tutor teaches kids I was
really amazed because in school we teach
for the test and so our whole focus is
to get kids to memorize things and then
give us back the right answer we don't
really focus on understanding and again
really hard to do when you have 30 kids
to stay with them and be infinitely
patient and stay with the kid that
doesn't quite get it until he or she
gets it it's really hard to do that but
with the tutor what we've noticed is
when a kid gets something wrong the
tutor's thinking about you know all the
possible and diving into all the
possible misconceptions that you have
and then it will help you get to the
right answer and discover the right
answer on your own so kids are walking
away with the depth of understanding
that they wouldn't get anywhere else
that's why it's so remarkable and this
is what real tutors do and the tutor
that we created you know it's it's made
meant to imitate the best tutors out
there and so what I often you know we
started with math this year and our
curriculum architect is called Dr James
tanton so he has a PhD from Princeton in
mathematics so he's obviously an expert
in his field he is the ambassador of the
mathematical Association in America he's
written 25 textbooks in math he has won
10 Awards of teaching Excellence
internationally so he's like the real
deal and when you meet him and you hear
him talk in the stories and he makes you
fall in love with math this is like the
teacher that every parent would want for
their kids
um and so now we've able to capture Dr
tantan through this digital device and
he even says it himself it's incredible
how the digital tutor ends up being even
better than me because it progresses
over time it captures all your stories
all your example your mistake and it
becomes even better than the actual
human itself and so imagine if you can
give this kind of education to your kids
how much more effective would it be the
learning process us and then all the
options that they would have after
school to actually work on the things
that they're interested in working
projects if they want to start a
business they can go ahead and do that
if they want to play sports if they want
to just be kids and have free play
whatever it is that they want so it's
really promising and I'm very excited
about that so when you have this
individual tutor this kind of one-on-one
tutor
um it's a machine it's not a person
right uh the kid knows it's a machine do
they
um are they more like sympathetic do
they uh change their behavior because
it's a machine versus a human like what
are some of the things you all are
seeing there so it's incredible because
the kids forget that it's that it's like
a digital tutor and you can all you know
you don't have to hear it from me you
can try it for free on synthesis.com
tutor it will blow your mind like it
throws you memes it says be right back I
need to use the restroom really quickly
it has like sounds it's talking to you
it gives you a workspace where you get
to like try things and it doesn't work
it talks to you it gives you stories it
remembers the things that you guys talk
about and it's like personal things
about your brother about you know this
trip that you had it will remember and
bring it back to you to the point where
kids actually feel
um that it's a real teacher and I'll
give you an example at the early days
when we first launched the tutor we
received an email from a really angry
parent saying you know there's a bug and
the bug is really affecting my daughter
because she's actually come to believe
that the tutor is is a real teacher and
so when the bug is saying something
nonsensical my daughter is you know
freaking out because she thinks that the
teacher is having a psychotic breakdown
and we're like whoa okay first of course
we need to be careful about the bugs and
we need to work on this we can't go too
fast that we break things but second and
most importantly whoa like she actually
thinks that this is a real human and so
that to us is the most important element
because again there has to be a
relationship you need to care about
whoever is teaching you something in
order for learning to actually happen
and so it's really remarkable like you
actually feel like you're learning in
this case from Dr tantan and so so
another example is one of the kids was
going through the orientation and was
clicking on the things it's actually for
the parent and the parent was behind him
and the parents like yeah just click yes
just because I want to hear and one of
the questions was um parent like do you
feel like your child sometimes struggles
to pick up on math concepts you know
right away and the parent was like tells
the son like well you don't but say yes
just because I want to see the answer
and the son turns around and he's like
Mom why would I lie to the tutor I can't
lie to the tutor so they actually feel
like there's a real human there and you
can again try it yourself so that you
experience I've never seen anything like
that like one of the things that I was
most hesitant about AI was like I was
like a computer can never replace a
human like that cannot happen like for
me when I was a teacher one of my
biggest qualities was that I was able to
Foster those really deep relationships
with my students they knew that I cared
and that incentivized them to learn so
it's like how can we possibly replace
that with AI but after trying it and
realizing how we've really captured the
essence of a human it's just remarkable
what are teachers saying about this or
they scared by it do they hate it they
like it so it's obviously a thread for
many teachers because that's where we're
heading and it's going to eventually
replace a lot of the teachers
um I haven't like particularly spoken to
teachers about it but um
are you not popular in the schools
anymore well no I actually wouldn't say
that because I I really always talk
about the hard effort that teachers like
teachers are not the problem the problem
is that teachers are stuck in this
Traditional School System that won't let
them do the things that they naturally
want to do to help kids learn and so I I
really don't think it's I actually think
the teachers are working really hard to
try to do the right thing but then you
know we get burned out by all the things
yeah
um but I think that you know eventually
this technology will be available for
schools that are you know willing to
change their ways and try something
different it will be available to
parents it will be a better kids even to
adults like it's just you know we're
trying right now a curriculum on
complexity science which you know you
usually don't learn until if anything
until like college and we're teaching it
to eight-year-olds and they're grasping
the content so really this technology
can be used for anyone to learn more
effectively in a more entertaining way
when you see these kids coming out of uh
these sessions how much of it is I
learned two plus two equals four right
from a math perspective uh versus they
can go and now they're doing something
in their day and they can recall it they
can apply it all that kind of stuff like
is it possible to in these sessions also
teach them the real world application
like you were talking about earlier the
schools don't have where now you can
almost like model out different
scenarios play different games those
types of things so everything we're
teaching them like if you look at the
way that Dr Tatton has structured the
math curriculum and again this is
available on our website you can see the
breakdown of what we're teaching and
when
he it's very very different from any
math curriculum that I've used in all
the schools that I've been to because
it's actually grounded on okay let's
start with a history of math like where
do numbers come from so it's it's kind
of crafted in a way that it builds your
understanding so we don't teach you like
two plus two equals four we go more into
the general concepts and you you end up
learning that but we actually focus on
the deep understanding because kids have
to build a number sense in order to be
able to execute all this like formulas
that then you know maybe a little bit
boring but if you understand math well
then you're able to do all that so
that's what we're focusing on so for
example the lesson that's available
online for anyone to try for free is how
to learn binary numbers so it's like how
computers work again you sometimes don't
learn this until college and so
um the way I mean I I taught binary
numbers in one of my schools and it's so
different from this lesson like I I
didn't even understand it and then I
didn't realize that until I tried the
digital tutor and I was like oh my God
this makes so much sense and so the way
that it works kids don't really realize
that they're learning math it's more
like we're learning something that we
can immediately use to understand
something better in the real world does
that make sense and again you need to
try to to kind of see that but
everything is relatable everything is
relevant there's an explanation unlike
in school for everything we do and the
interesting thing is that that's one of
our products at the digital tutor but
for both the digital tutor and the
simulations the complex team simulations
that was their first product where kids
learn the soft skills that they don't
learn in school that they're going to
need in the future like how to
communicate how to problem solve how to
work in teams how to react when
something you know Under Pressure how to
make trade-offs how to engage in
conjecture and criticism how to fail and
pick yourself up and pivot like all
these things and how to figure things
out when you don't have instructions all
these things are fundamental for you to
do whatever it is that you're going to
do in the future it doesn't matter and
we're not teaching it in school and so
both of our products are grounded on
this counter-intuitive insights that
kids want to learn and kids want to be
challenged and so in school they they
give you a speed limit right they put
you by grades you learn up to here
according to the curriculum kids are
bored some kids don't get it at
synthesis we have no spit limits so we
will push you as fast and as far as
you're willing to go and this is very
very different
um and so everything we do is based on
real challenges that kids have to solve
you know real problems and when you
think about it
what do we know about the world that our
kids are going to inherit that's
constantly changing and chaotic right
what do we know we know that kids are
going to have to work in groups and
collaboratively with people from
different backgrounds different cultures
different ways of thinking we know that
kids are going to have to Grapple with
complexity that doesn't come with
instructions and that's hard and you
know to figure out real problems and we
know that they're going to do both of
these things on their own they're not
going to have an adult or a teacher or a
parent telling them what to do or
instructions and so how do we prepare
kids for that kind of future we need to
give them practice working in teams
working with different groups and we
need to give them practice grappling
with complexity if you think about what
most of the Innovative companies do they
all tend to do the same thing they align
teams on a mission that everyone
understands and then they hire the kinds
of people that are going to make the
team better few things in the world are
achieved alone right like if you think
about our biggest problems the way that
we achieve things and we find answers to
our complex problem is by working
collaboratively and being aligned on a
shared Mission think of SpaceX think of
NASA think of Apple right so we often
talk about the remarkable people that
are changing the world but it's really
the hard work of dedicated teams of
people that are making a difference in
the world so how do we give kids
practice constant practice working in
teams to solve society's greatest
problems and that's what we're doing in
synthesis and I think that that's the
kind of education that we should be
focusing on I mean I believe I've
invested in the company multiple times
uh and think that you guys are on the
right path here one of the things with
the tutor that's really interesting to
me is the ability to change teachers how
many schools did you go to so I went to
10 schools growing up okay so I went to
six over 12 years and I always in
hindsight looked at it as you kind of
earn the lottery like what school did
you end up in who the teacher was and if
you're in fifth grade math there's no
changing the fifth grade math teacher
like that's who you got and if they're
great awesome if they're not great
that's just the luck of the draw but
also uh they could be good for one
student and not good for another and so
it's a matchmaking almost to some degree
with this it seems like what you could
basically do is if a student is using a
tutor and for whatever reason they're
not really kind of compatible they don't
feel like they're learning you
eventually over time could have multiple
tutors and you just swap it out with the
Press of a button and there's a
different tutor with a different style
or different you know
um kind of uh uh humor or whatever to
really engage the kid right yeah well we
actually have
um different voices different
um accents and you know if you prefer a
female teacher or a male teacher like we
actually have that the the basics of it
it's still Dr tantan and his ideas and
the way that he teaches but the other
thing that's amazing is that the the
tutor is adaptive and so it will catch
on the way that you think and how long
you take to solve a problem and where
you're stuck and it will over time
obviously you can't see this after one
session your kid has to go doing
multiple you know through multiple
sessions for it to start mapping out you
know how does Anthony learn and then it
will teach two years style it's really
personalized and I mean this like when I
worked in schools we would often get
like oh this is the new app and it's
personalized learning and it will pick
up on you no it will track how many
right answers you got and it will you
know but it's not like what we're
talking about like real adaptive
learning So eventually what we want to
do is spot this incredible teachers you
know in physics in math we would have
the math one in science and all these
subjects and capture everything that and
it could be multiple teachers right like
you were saying and capture the way what
makes them so remarkable and so so great
because remember that in order to be a
good teacher is not only being an expert
in your field you also need to
understand the art of teaching and so
finding that person is difficult but
once we find them and we're able to
capture their Essence it can be multiple
again
um that's really where the magic happens
right and then with this adaptive
programs and again we're just getting
started this is just going to get better
and better over time but we really think
that we're going to get the results that
the DARPA team got with this you know
when they first tried out this
technology and it would be you know
we're solving the biggest problem in
education right now and so it's really
remarkable where can people go try the
tutor if they want to try it
synthesis.com tutor and you can try
again the binary lesson is available for
free and you can also look at the
content that we're coming up for
um next year with all the different
topics all right now I want to talk
about this book The Learning game
teaching kids to think for themselves
Embrace Challenge and love learning
one of the things schools do a really
good job of at least they try to is
teaching you what to think
it sounds like this book is much more
focused on how to think and as I've read
it I think
the critical thinking the independent
thought all of these pieces of uh of
thinking that people understand are
important right if you ask someone like
hey it's critical thinking good they're
like yes independent thought good
they're like yes
but no one ever teaches you how to do it
and so what do you think is kind of the
path to being able to teach that
critical thinking and independent
thought whether somebody is a
kindergartner they're a high schooler or
even an adult in many cases still needs
to learn how to do that absolutely so
again you said it right schools are not
teaching you how to think they're
teaching you what to think that's why
we're so focused on this
one-size-fits-all curriculum that's why
we're focused on you know assessing
everyone the same way and teaching the
same subjects to everyone but actually
in order to teach kids how to think you
have to do things
you know the opposite of what we're
doing in school so you need to give kids
opportunities to question things and you
need to teach them what's the right way
to question things and you know schools
have sort of this aversion when kids
question the teacher because it's like
it's considered disrespectful or like a
threat to Authority and the reality is
that oftentimes we don't have the
answers they're like well why are we
learning this we don't even know because
we look at the content and we're like I
don't know when you're ever going to use
this in your life and so the way to sort
of like react to this like don't
question things but really when kids
question when we question things we
innovate like that is how we get to you
know different answers to different
problems and so teaching your child how
to be a skeptic and really um engage in
you know that that's one of the the the
main things like letting your kid
question everything and teaching them
how to question things also surrounding
them unfortunately school is filled with
conventionally minded people
um again because we train them that way
everyone's doing the same thing at the
same time and and so trying to find
Alternatives outside of school where
your kid is exposed too and with the
internet this is really easy right there
are a bunch of learning communities with
kids from all over the world so you're
not just stuck with the kids in school
and you know that are very similar to
you but you expose them to kids that
will challenge their thinking or adults
you know that will challenge their
thinking that will you know that have
different biases that you have to detect
and you again one of the best ways to do
this is to engage them in solving
problems because that's where you know
you hear these kids talking and
communicating and all these things will
come up and you let them you don't
intervene so a lot of what happens in
school is that we're trying to
um script everything and give them
instructions for everything and make
sure that they are on the right but
really one of the main things is just
letting your kid you know struggle
letting your kid get confused to letting
you get and then that is where he starts
or she starts learning really what you
know how to do it on their own when you
don't intervene when you don't give them
instructions and so a lot of it is you
know when you think two two very
important skills that kids will need in
order to learn how to think for
themselves is how to figure things out
for themselves and how to fail and pick
themselves up and keep going like these
are two things that you're going to keep
doing for the rest of your life we in
school learn not to fail because you
know you make a mistake and you get that
bad grade then it's in your report card
and then it haunts you for the rest of
your life but if you think about it
failure is going to be part of your life
forever and when is a time where you
should be able to learn how to fail when
you're a kid when the stakes are low
right like when it doesn't mean like you
know if you start to practice how to
fail when you're an adult you can mean a
failed marriage a failed business like
that's catastrophic failure how do we
avoid that by giving them practice over
and over and over again a great way to
do it and people are against this but
video games if you look at video games
kids are constantly failing and they
pick themselves up and they're like okay
what did I learn what do I need to do
next time to get better and so they keep
going and they keep going and they're
getting that exposure to failure video
games are not the only way but it's one
way so you expose kids to failure at an
early age and you walk them through how
to react when they don't get things
right and what do they learn about it so
you kind of like re-shape the way that
we think about failure and then figuring
things out like something that we do
really well at synthesis is we throw
kids in this simulations and we don't
tell them what to do and the kids are so
frustrated because they don't know what
to do when you don't give them
instructions it's incredible like they
get super frustrated and we're like
you're gonna have to figure it out
because in the in the real world nobody
wants to hire somebody that they need to
tell you what to do all the time they
want people that are proactive that
figure things out how can we expect for
kids to know how to do that if we don't
give them practice so that's another
thing that you do to teach kids how to
think for themselves
what can parents do to make their kids
smarter right like you're talking about
making them anti-fragile and there's a
whole chapter in the book and and kind
of having skin in the game and things
like that but what could a parent do
that increases the probability of their
kid being a problem solver being
intelligent all of those things like
obviously go sign up for synthesis right
would be one thing but like what else
can they be doing uh kind of in their
home or when they're interacting with
their children yeah so first find out if
because the system does work for some
people so if your kid is thriving in the
school system then great you know that
was good but the first thing is figuring
out if if that's the right way of
learning if you don't see them excited
to or wanting to keep learning or or
being challenged in the appropriate way
then you need to find Alternatives you
need to find and nowadays there are a
bunch of things that people are coming
up with in the alternative education
space that are really appealing and that
could work for your family and so it's a
matter of Having the courage to venture
out and try something different and if
it doesn't work you try something else
but for example
um you have a lot of forest schools
nowadays where kids are actually
learning in nature and learning about
things that they come up with so excuse
me what is that they're called Forest
schools like like go into the woods well
yeah but also it could be the beach like
they're called Forest schools but it
could mean like you know wherever you're
but outdoors and instead of kids
learning from a curriculum they're
learning from things that they encounter
in nature or things and so it's it's
immediately relevant to whatever it is
that the kids are learning so it's like
a persistent field trip it's like a
persistent field trip and believe it or
not damn my parents were screwing up
exactly and you can imagine kids are
active kids are moving around they're
socializing they're actually learning
from real things and so there's no
textbook or curriculum or no it's like
it's you know it's very unstructured and
some people are like oh whoa like no but
when they learn math or they just learn
like how to like start fires
no they do they do learn the subjects uh
you know through what they're
encountering and then they go and they
meet and they have like a circle and
they actually go over and there is some
direct teaching that happens but it's
like based on whatever it is that they
are encountering so that's an
it's more relevant than that but but
anyway what I'm trying to say is when
people
um look at the edge you know they're
like Anna okay I understand the system's
broken I know that it doesn't work but I
can't homeschool my kid and and I'm like
well you need to think about education
as a spectrum on the far left you have
you know the traditional school system
and on the far right you have
homeschooling or World schooling which
are the parents that travel with their
kids which I think is fantastic or on
schooling where parents actually don't
do anything about it and they just
expect their kids to learn on their own
so and you have you don't have to go you
know all the way to that extreme there
are a bunch of options in the middle
that you can actually choose from and
and you know find an alternative that's
better for your family and so what I
talk about in my book I give parents
Alternatives I give parents options but
then I don't necessarily try to convince
them you know you have to take your kid
out of school tomorrow I mean although
some of them may but I I kind of paint a
picture of why our current school system
is no longer meeting the needs of our
kids to today and why it's so important
that we course correct this now and why
we need more people working on this now
um so that more Alternatives can be
available and now with all like the
school choice and all these things it's
really giving power parents the
possibility to engage their kids in
different learning Alternatives and so I
would say yeah like having the the like
a lot of parents are scared that they
would make a mistake and they're like oh
this is my want chance but the reality
no and you know and I've been through
the system when people ask me what am I
going to do with my kids I'm like I'm
not concerned about because I already
know what happens in school and there's
very little learning so whatever happens
outside of school is going to be more
productive I was gonna say every parent
does homeschool
right when your kid gets off school at
whatever three o'clock four o'clock 4 30
whatever time school gets out these days
uh and they go home even if you work
three jobs and you see your kid for 10
minutes a day you're teaching them
something they're going to emulate you
they're gonna mimic you they're they're
going to do something they're going to
extract some sort of information from
you and
unfortunately sometimes it's bad
information sometimes it's good
information but I think that everyone
homeschools their kid to some degree is
an idea that most people don't think of
it that way because like you know I send
my kid to school but if we could switch
that thought process it probably would
have a bigger impact on them right
absolutely and I think that one of the
first steps to do that
well where did this
come from because a lot of people are
like oh I went through the system and I
turned out fine but if you really stop
and you think about deep you know deep
thoughts of your school experience and
you realize how many hours were wasted
how much more productive your time could
have been spent as a kid if we did
something different and when you stop
and think about well where did education
come from like does it make sense for
what's for our needs today I think
that's when parents start to be like oh
because education used to be the job of
parents and teachers and like one-on-one
tutors and the church but this started
to change about 200 years ago in a
region of Germany called Prussia so at
the time you know they had been defeated
terribly by Napoleon and so the
government leaders were like okay we
need to take charge of educating the
younger population so that they're ready
for this not to happen again to fight
War so the goal of Education was to
train kids for the military so that they
never got defeated again and that was
what actually started the basis of our
modern school system so this idea of
specialized buildings having a squat
children which was a teacher that would
teach the subjects extended school year
mandated attendance a standardized
curriculum like all these ideas came
from that so again education was used as
you know nation building and so that
started to change
um with World War II when you know World
War II revealed the importance of a
nation's manufacturing capacity and so
the United States obviously dominated
because their assembly line and
factories could produce better and
stronger tanks and bombs and guns and
everything than their enemies and so the
goal shifted from training a generation
of soldiers to fight War to training
people to be manager fact you know to
manage factories and work in the
assembly line so the United States led
the next development of education you
know in history and so the theme was
standardization and efficiency so they
would group kids by age they would put
them all through the same curriculum
they would hire specialized teachers to
teach its subject they would extend the
school day so so that they would
maximize output they would reduce things
like you know talking and playing and
all the things that make you know
socializing so that they would minimize
waste and anyone who did not feel fit
the mold was labeled as defective so
literally the whole system was you know
modeled to you know a factory and so
then around 1960s we had this whole idea
of like oh let's use standardized test
to sort of measure if things are working
and so it would work like
um kind of similar like when a
manufacturer wants to see if a car is
working so this assessments would use
they would use them as quality control
and so they would serve for
administrators to know you know as
reassurance that their system was
working and to keep schools accountable
it's very hard to see the benefits of
the modern school system in the United
States so over you know in the past 50
years standardized test scores have
improved only by a small margin you
would think that a system that was
designed to train Factory managers would
Advance a nation's productivity and
standard of living but actually since
the 1970s everything you know the the
rate of improvement has actually
declined so nowadays half of Americans
can't read Beyond sixth grade level and
if you look at the confidence in public
schools is at an all-time low like it's
even below government and big businesses
and if you look at our most famous
inventors out there like you know Bill
Gates and Steve Jobs and Oprah Winfrey
and Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg
they're all famous for dropping out of
their degree programs and their stories
are so powerful because they all
highlight something that every student
feels like what's the point of school
clearly it was designed for a very very
different time for a very different
purpose yet we continue to use the same
model and if parents realize this and
realize that they're not preparing kids
for the kind of world that we're living
in I think that they would say okay this
is priority I need to find alternatives
I completely agree
um where can we send people to find this
book The Learning game teaching kids to
think for themselves Embrace Challenge
and love learning
that's what it looks like where can we
send people
um yeah so you can pre-order the book on
Amazon Barnes Noble like anywhere Thrift
Books anywhere where you order books the
book comes out September 5th so in a
month
um yeah so you can find it and when
people read this and if they sign their
kid up for synthesis what is the idea is
it that it replaces school or it is a
supplement to Traditional School or
whatever they're already doing so for
synthesis right now we're working on
building that alternative model
eventually we will have a full stack
replacement for the K-12 model right now
we have two pro you know you know we're
trying to do that one remarkable product
at a time right now we have two products
a digital tutor for hardcore academics
and team simulations for the soft skills
and so you can start by that as an
enrichment program eventually you can
actually sign up and it will replace all
of your kids education and in terms of
the book well the book is for you know
teachers and schools that are looking to
change their ways students or kids that
want to fall in love with learning again
and parents that are frustrated did with
the options available for their children
and really anyone who wants to unlearn
those unhelpful lessons taught in school
so that they can make room to learn the
things that will actually serve them in
the real world and so my hope with the
book is that whoever reads it will gain
confidence to rethink education for
themselves to venture out and try new
methods old and new actually because a
lot of them are old ideas that are still
relevant today
to have the courage to unlearn the
things that again are not helpful and
hopefully find an alternative that works
for their family so
one last question for you I was texting
with your husband before this episode
and
uh he's an amazing guy what is one thing
that you've learned from Fernando over
the years that you will forever remember
um so
husband is very very different from me
like actually the school system worked
wonders for him and so I'm here like the
rebel educator trying to do things and
now we're trying to raise a kid so you
can imagine our conversations at home
but I think that he's taught me
um the value of balance and really
finding you know it's not just my ideas
and the way I think about things I
always have to contemplate the counter
argument and I think that yeah he's
taught me
to have a balance and to and to see both
sides of things
he had to give you a grade on your
ability to have balance today what do
you think he would give you I think he
would give me a B plus
okay
we'll have to ask him all right thank
you so much for uh for doing this where
can we send people to find you on the
internet
um you can find me on Twitter at Anna
fabrega11
um you can find me on YouTube also
miss Fab you can find me on Instagram
Miss Fab underscore learning lab
um and you can sign up for my newsletter
Fab Fridays on sub stack awesome all
right thank you so much we'll do it
again thank you so much for having me